okay I thought I seen smoke come out of
here yeah okay
how about say all no bro
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wakes and
today I'm joined by Wiz Khalifa he's a
platinum-selling artist with more than a
decade in the rap game his latest album
rolling papers - is out now and you can
catch him on the dazed and blazed tour
coming to a city near you
Wiz Khalifa welcome to the show - up
dude chillin how about you bro
big chillin well want to start by
bringing up a rostrum records vlog from
2009 there was a camera crew following
you around New York City and you said
none of that spicy [__] man I don't like
hot food [__] all that I like to enjoy
my food yeah what's your mindset going
into this I like spicy now I was younger
back then you know I got a little bit
older tastes changed developed thing
from the spicy a more evolved palette
from Wiz Khalifa baby ready to get it
going let's do this
[Music]
all right so this first one is the
howler monkey howler monkey yep
okay started the handle not that bad
so lately you've been obsessed with
working out more specifically Muay Thai
at that hyper exclusive gym and West
Hollywood unbreakable mm-hmm that's such
an interesting scene there cuz you could
be working out alongside uh sure one day
and then Chris Pratt the next when you
think about all the larger-than-life
people that you shared a gym with B its
Sylvester Stallone or what have you
there a story that stands out um I think
they're all pretty unique especially
like sparring with some of the guys like
I got this far with Chuck Liddell
freaking Randy Couture tyron woodley
who's the UFC champ now so it's like
there's no real filter in between it's
like you just right there with those
people and you just get it all so it's
all pretty unique to me and then Jay
Glazer actually said that you're the
only person to ever hurt him with a body
shot yeah he trains with the likes of
Randy Couture and check it out what's
the secret to throwing a really strong
hook for real throws a lot of rotation
like just in the hips and like you gotta
throw some body off so it's like with
Jay I just caught him we were like up
close with each other and I I faked him
high and he went high and I seen help
and I'm just snuggling snuggling in real
quick have you ever put in a position
where you had to defend yourself what
would be your go-to combination my go-to
combination if I had to defend myself I
probably just do a nice little team just
kick somebody in the face right from
real far away
[Music]
heartbeat sauce all right I taste good
kinda sweet as Taylor Gang knows you rep
Pittsburgh to the fullest on wing to I'm
hoping to get whizzes guide to the Steel
City what can you tell the people about
eatin Park have you ever ended a burn
ride there yeah I mean you always end up
at eating pork there's like one of the
only places that stays open 24 hours in
Pittsburgh there's one a Squirrel Hill
there's one at homestead there's one all
the way out like by the north side do
you have an opinion on the best pizza
and squirrel Park Minnie O's or Aiello's
there's like a difference in the
cheese's it just depends on how cheesy
you want to go that day but I'm not I'm
not picky and then there's a lot of
crazy [__] in Pittsburgh via the
Mattress Factory or the Cathedral of
Education can you recommend to go to
tourist attraction for when you're under
the influence under the influence go to
the Science Center
now that you've traveled the world and
you've toured the country as Primanti
Brothers still the most innovative
sandwich you've ever come across I think
so especially based off of the bread and
the in the meat in fryer combination
it's just it's so good and so cool I
never had anything that was like that
innovative ever you're right
do you have a favorite gender expression
Pittsburgh slang always cracks me up um
instead of saying like that like they'll
say like at I like I like when they say
pirates Lantern I got a carefully eat
this I'm not diving in like yeah you're
a wild boy oh that's like a mustard eat
mm-hmm mustard sauce but still no
problem it's kind of leap violently
oh [__] I just licked my finger this
hot-ass shiner it's a rookie mistake
there yeah you can't do that
not never again let's do this so a
couple years ago we interviewed Chevy
Woods about his role as Taylor gangsta
facto chef the Chevy would still get
down like that in the kitchen
yeah Chevy gets big especially being
that uh we all work out now it's almost
like [__] gotta eat and then I saw
recently you posted a picture with
sulfate did you eat at his restaurant
and if so doesn't live up to the mean
yeah I definitely a I saw Bay's
restaurant and it's really really
[__] good I guess amazing when it's
not a home-cooked meal you have a go-to
spot when you're on the road I usually
try to hit up famous spots I in the heat
city so I was like if I'm in Chicago
going to Harold's right away whatever's
pop in there like that's what I like to
eat
for the uninitiated can you explain the
power of Nando's Nando's Wow because you
really don't get in a good American food
overseas that's the closest it's a home
tastes in like they got the spicy they
got the rice they got the core and they
got all the stuff that you need so it's
like when artists travel to UK or
wherever they try to fly the dad knows
for sure all right where's you ready to
move on I think so
all right so this next one is the son of
zombie Oh what wise what so this is on
be child oh yeah [__] that one
that's just stupid though we're in it
it's a down taste so I think I speak for
most of the internet when I say one of
the most heartwarming things is when we
see pictures of you and your son
Sebastian nice and then I know that
being a rap dad it's probably great in a
lot of ways but do you ever find that
being a famous rapper intersects with
being a rap dad and weird or humorous
ways I want him to know how awesome I am
and how awesome my career is but it's
like just playing with him and being
there it's like what really matters to
him being a kid so I just kind of just
balanced the cool with the with the
normal how has beaten a dad affected
your style because I know that you said
you made the dad hat popular but
recently you tweeted time for a new hat
to come in style yeah it hats are
annoying yeah I just feel like
everybody's wearing the same hat it
sucks but uh being a dad like I don't
feel like it changed my style too much I
guess I got cool dad swag no uh-uh
can you pull back the curtain on that
fifth birthday because even you seem to
be surprised with how hard it was
ringing off yeah no I was cool man it
was fun his mom did a great job planning
it I got drunk as [__] never thought
that you could have a cool ass
five-year-old birthday party a Dave &
Buster's but it went down
[Music]
my [__] zombie son I only like him
[__] that guy be careful how you just
[__] I think I'm still numb from the
last one
all right was Babri every current
segment on our show called explain that
Graham where I do a deep dive and I
guess Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context okay so
I'll bust out the laptop I'll show you
the picture then you just tell me the
bigger story is that sound good sweet
all right laptop please Thank You
Stephen thanks Tina
you probably have a lot of sauce on
those keys yeah I've put this through a
lot saucy has hot hot wing laptop all
right so first things first
here you are bowling it's important to
point out I think that you're wearing
those supreme Slayer sweatpants yeah
this is this just everyday bowling
attire yeah but I was in my room in
Vegas they have a room where you could
Bowl in the room a suite the lanes
[__] suck oh really oh it was
terrible I'm just what I was so
frustrated cuz I know besides we tie in
pool bowling that's a big hobby for you
yeah I left the ball
have you ever bowled a perfect game not
yet what's her high score 267 so you're
close close almost there
let me get it and lastly what do you
remember about this night is that jay-z
that's jay-z and Kevin Hart a very
powerful VIP section yeah I remember we
were at a grace note I think back then
that's what gray stone was still papa
and uh I was talking to Ken and he was
like here's my quiz how do you do that
and I was I would I thought he's talking
about like smoking weed and drinking at
the same time is how do you do that man
I was like what you mean he was like how
did you reach down there and touch that
nigga's hand from all the way up there
he's like I'm sure this [__] I can't do
that [__] hey and I started crying out
by those [__] seriously funny as hell
and I tried to get jay-z to smoke weed
but he didn't you know on a dope had
though smoke some dope
this next one is the bravado Carolina
Reaper sauce oh you know about Carolina
Reapers I've seen you eat that
oh [__] with chilli class yeah with
chilli he was [__] hiccup in and [__]
she was hilarious
snap him yeah he loved it I think it's a
little bit Oh what that my Scandinavian
good garson's go made me Higa and snap
mm-hmm that's good but I know about the
[__] Reaper so this ain't [__]
compared to just poppin of a pod
straight I bet
oh that's good I'll buy that mmm that's
good
it's hot whoa it creeps a little bit so
I know that's smoking it's more than
just a pastime for you ah you have your
own strain Khalifa cush and then of
course the rolling papers with
resistance I have a Forbes list stoner
in front of me I want to dive into the
business of weed can you give us an
idiot's guide to this CBD craze that no
one will shut the [__] up about it's
really cool cuz they take the THC out of
the weed there's different components in
pot that affect your body the THC is the
one that gives you the effect that you
feel high in CBD or cannabinoids that's
the health benefits that you get as it
brings that out and it's good for sleep
it's good for reducing pain and I think
what are the more interesting things
that I've seen now that it's legalized
in places like California is you walk
into these stores and it's just product
all over the place so I feel like that's
what the market is these days it's like
trying to get stoned on the low as
opposed to like just smoking a joint you
know what I mean like right I feel like
in the future smoking pot is actually
going to be like really old school and
just ingesting in all these different
other ways is gonna be the way to really
get hurt when Snoop was on one of the
Jimmy's Jimmy Kimmel you said that when
you guys were on tour together that
you'd compete in the smoke Olympics yeah
who can roll faster you are Snoop he's
world's faster than me
he definitely rolls faster and more
efficient there's been times where I've
been thinking I was a little roll like
the best joint in the world
and he'll just be quiet for like two
seconds guys here nephew I'll be like
down like this it'd just be perfect
right away so his experience in the game
as it's proven every time where do you
have the gold medal on him I got the
gold medal probably just on lungs like a
mouth because that's fast yeah I smoke
joints I do bongs I do dads and all that
like he'll do that to hang with me
lighting it like [__] I'm not gonna let
you like I'll smoke me but he don't do
all of that on the regular and
me like I'm doing that all day and then
I know that you're a very skilled
marketer if you were to make a THC
infused hot sauce what would it taste
like and what would you call it
it will probably taste like one of these
sweeter ones mhm and I will probably
call it sweet [__] next one is the bun
stirs of Australia okay
oh yeah I got some hot [__] down there
mm-hmm
16:10 heat was that mean it means it's
off the charts I think I was 16 out of
ten mm-hmm [__] hot no whoa I don't like
it so when you performed on Saturday
Night Live a few years ago you did a
promo spot you talked about how you have
more than 400 tattoos what can you tell
the people about your go-to tattoo
artists Tookie Carter he's crazy he's
super funny he's got a heavy hand so you
can't [__] sit with him and not that
we can't be a [__] if you go to he's
really good he draws everything like
right on you he doesn't use stencils so
that's why I like that
what's the last thing he tattooed on you
I think this pumpkin or the I think I
got to spray can in the pumpkin he's had
his nails on my face he's y'all yeah I
don't know we're just like somewhere
around here my son likes pumpkins he
loves or and she loves Halloween just
break had as part of the Taylor Gang son
we got like the fence just break in and
then can you talk about the philosophy I
think I was rapper stuck in my tooth and
that's not cool because like making it
more hot right it's stuck in there what
was you saying can you talk to me about
the philosophy of tattooing for yourself
because I've heard you say that you want
your tattoos to tell your life story on
your body it's really like [__] that I
learn through our life yeah just leave
those experiences open for later on in
life and that's what the tattoos are and
I still got room on my legs like the
back Molly
like that so that's where the tattoos
are gonna go when you're 80 yeah yep all
right was you ready to move on
[__] it's the superhot one right this is
hop now let me get some skin bro I gotta
stop by swishing it around in my mouth
right it does now it's mine to learn as
not some Marcel cause it's like swishing
it is just like dude this one actually
isn't as bad as that one really that
black label that [__] monsters I like
that beyond insanity actually hot bro
you're telling me I'm sorry I feel like
I'm read like you dawg this [__] is
crazy
alright come on what's up so growing up
I know you dreamed of being in a rap
crew and you'd oftentimes defend the
diplomats to your friends in Oklahoma
who just wanted to listen to chopped and
screwed music so with that in mind I
wanted to show you some of the great big
my eyes out bro I hate this I want to
show you some of the great rap crews of
all time and you give me your take to
what extent if at all they influenced
you does that sound good yeah all right
laptop please oh my god my tongue hurts
this is probably like when a cat's
tongue feels like all the time they
think it's a game they think it's a game
ah man it's not good bro does milk
really help so dude I actually a
question I know but if there's it's
there's nuance to it you know here's the
thing help me this doesn't milk work the
milk helps okay is it gonna cure you
no no of course okay it helps little
splash
okay a little bit better Ram yeah yeah
yeah so just go ahead and hit that milk
first things first
thank you for that real answer bro I'm
here for you I appreciate it all right
first things first
come thugs-n-harmony love them like my
first experiences will rap music I was
listening the bone got a tattoo little
marmalade yep
love though got three 6 mafia yeah yeah
love three 6 mafia
it was my guys heavily influenced by
them probably started getting high like
on the regular because of them in their
music so shout out the three six alright
one more for ya dip cert love Dipset got
it two arguments over dip set my real
name is cam so it's like you know Killa
cam was my walkout music it from like if
I'm dip set for life what kind of
arguments would you get into right cuz
you're living in Oklahoma everyone could
rat you know like when he was on like
the tutti fruity fruity louie wave but
I'm not you couldn't you couldn't tell
me that oh yeah
alright we got more are you still in the
game was yeah my mustache is hot
hail fire let's go okay I thought I seen
smoke come out of here yeah I was gonna
say I don't know bro
[Music]
pick a side
go for it don't let it linger get it out
the way feel like I'm in the gym Lata
okay yeah
now my whole throat just got hot from
now on mm-hmm that wasn't just the lips
yeah oh oh [__] welcome to the
terrordome oh [__] ha ha that's what you
give somebody when you want in the
snitch so your often-cited is one of the
first rappers to leverage the power of
the internet do you think that that's an
accurate assessment no I could say I'm
one of them but I would say Soulja Boy
is like the first if you're stuck on a
desert island with a lifetime supply of
Khalifa Kush what would be one show one
movie and one website you need to hold
you over one show power cuz I love power
is its power let me say power thanks bye
guys how we say power one movie in it a
dragon and you say one website Twitter
there it is was Khalifa yeah baby
[Music]
alright so this is the last dab Redux we
call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing you don't have to
if you don't want to I don't want to the
analytic
[Music]
I don't know dealer [__] I ain't no
[__] why is it's just so thick pause
there you go there you go
oh it was called the last mm-hmm always
y'all sauce this [__] probably ain't
even hot oh you want to walk that one
back a little bit
ya ready I'm ready alright let's do this
Cheers
[Music]
I switch side oh that's so hot
alright Wiz Kalifa here we are at the
end of the gauntlet and as we've
discussed today there are many sides of
Wiz rapper contra preneur father but
like one side that we haven't explored
is your burgeoning voice actor career
mmm
whether it's playing on Bojack horseman
or doing a character on American Dad but
I know that your dream doesn't end there
was my dream gig is to have like a
Disney movie like a whole [__] movie
with my voice behind it I could be
support I could be the homie I want to
be in a whole movie meet now that you
have a bajillion scovilles going through
you write hot sauce in every corner of
your mouth yeah where can you hit the
people with a sample of what that voice
acting ball might sound like it's gonna
sound just like this it's very clear now
I got the pepper and [__] like that so
we good we good we good
Obie digital surround sound IMAX here
right through the head whoa and look at
you with Khalifa all the way through the
gauntlet could have quit at the bomb but
you didn't you held it out yeah came
through and now I just have to roll out
the red carpet for you my man this
camera this camera at this camera let
the people know what you have going on
rolling papers to is out now all the
videos from rolling papers to are out
now make sure you check them out hit me
up on Instagram Twitter YouTube Khalifa
Kush KK everything and roll papers too
good job with you feeling good whoa
she's hot yo the cool thing about it is
like they're all like semi enjoyable
right like it's not like oh I'm about to
run the [__] out of here and like rip my
tongue I was like I could see why people
eat this [__] yeah exactly it's like a
labor exactly because there's like
mustardy and and there's like peppery
and and there's like [__]
whoo Aloha spice Lords if you're
wondering why I'm sitting on this
beautiful beach it's because I'm
celebrating Lowe's calientes the sauce
of summer in the newest addition to the
hot ones hot sauce family this is Beach
vibes in a bottle sweet smoky spicy and
I might be biased but I think it's the
best hot sauce we've ever made and
here's the exciting news if you want to
pick up a bottle it's available now you
know the drill heat nice calm Heaton is
calm for your bottle of lows calientes
lows calientes muy delicioso
[Music]